there's this this this trope i guess
this um i guess you can call it trope
that liberals won't survive the
apocalypse that people in cities they
don't know how to survive they don't
know how to hunt and there's a lot of
people who are more uh rural who believe
they'll probably fare better i think
it's a it's a bit of a fair assessment
you know luke was saying these these
starbucks hippies aren't going to do so
well when when the ish hits the fan and
maybe these guys who got farms or at
least know how to deal with chickens
might do better but you know you've
traveled around you've met people of all
different backgrounds all the different
dirty jobs how do you feel about that do
you think that's just a myth
well
if you had to choose a side
you know i mean it's walking dead time
okay like we're like you're you're gonna
have to hunker down
in a place that is primarily
populated with
well-educated thoughtful
writers and thinkers
or
hunters and gatherers and builders
what
what team do you go on when things get
sporty
look well that's why i'd say i'd go to
the countryside and find some more look
around i mean look you've answered your
own code
i can see i can see where you're coming
from and from where i've been i i know
what i would choose
look i'm
it's weird for me after 20 years of
dirty jobs because people see that show
and they figure that i'm that guy
i mean they figure that i can fix or
build or replicate
anything
you know and i don't know why because i
i never do it on the show i simply bear
witness and work as an apprentice
to people who can actually do it i
actually can't i mean that gene is
recessive my granddad had it but i
didn't you know dirty jobs was a love
letter to him that's another story my
point is
you know when we lost power for four
days in northern california
at the height of the
lockdowns i never felt
more helpless
there's nothing i could do except watch
my meat
in the refrigerator slowly rot
and watch as the temperature of the
house slowly rose
and the thick arid smoke of the
wildfires just drifted down and a plague
of ants somehow on top of all of this is
in the house they everything was just
crapping the bed contemporaneously it
was a remarkably grim time
and then our teeth you know there's no
tv there's no and it's like my whole
life
is held together with pipes and cables
and wires and the men and women who have
the know-how
to fix them when they go down
whatever little hiccup you just had here
i had a similar one during that time and
we lost a prime time tv show you know we
were 50 minutes through and we lost the
whole thing had to start from scratch
but that's nothing when you think about
real
real power outages
look the heroes of our workforce and i
use that word very very very rarely but
i use it now because
we're in short supply
it's the linemen it's the people that
are
anybody who shares my addiction to
smooth roads and runways and affordable
electricity and indoor plumbing you know
we're the people who need to be most
involved in this conversation do you run
a foul of people that let me promote or
just stand by and watch planned
obsolescence run it's or like or does
that come up constantly are you like we
got to fix this thing because it's
broken because it was built to break so
that they can sell us another one later
that's so i mean yes is the short answer
the funnier answer is
i played uh i played tim allen's younger
brother on last man standing and the
first episode i did with him we were
standing backstage waiting for our
entrance
and we were talking about he this exact
topic came up and tim like lost his mind
telling me a story about how a blender
broke and how he wanted to fix it with
his grandson to show him
show him how a thing can be salvaged and
repaired but of course it can't because
the whole thing's like two pieces of
extruded plastic and it wasn't designed
to be fixed it was designed to fail
and uh yeah we missed our cue because
tim allen was was screaming about
planned obsolescence you ever seen the
ted talk from the guy who tried to make
a toaster from scratch
yeah it's amazing isn't it yeah he
couldn't do it can't do it can't be done
so it could be done in the sense that
maybe if he if he tried making a steel
toaster but the plastic he could not do
right
it's amazing to me that
the technology we have
in the civilization is dependent upon
hyper-specific specialties
a computer is not just made by one
person or something like a computer it's
made by probably what several dozen
specialists in all these different areas
and more than dozens because if you
really want to get down to it you have
this factory that can make the chips
that runs the machines that talks about
the coolant fluid and all that stuff but
then you've got the people who are going
to source the chemicals for you the
people who are going to source the
metals for it refine the metals it
probably takes how many i i bet somebody
in the audience might actually know this
how many specialties does it take to
make one modern computer 300 400 more
probably more but the guy who mines the
copper
yeah
isn't it funny though about
how when you talk about what it takes to
make this thing right or the computer
right whatever little piece of tech
you're most currently enamored of
um
all of the companies responsible
want to position themselves as
innovators
because there's great sexiness that
comes with being an innovator i don't
care whether you're apple or google or
intel you go down the list and they all
talk about their incredible ability to
think ahead and innovate when in reality
their real talent the dirty jobs talent
is their ability to replicate
it's not enough to make one of these
things you guys all want one in fact if
you can't make a billion of them these
days you don't really have a business
so language matters and when you
see people
work so hard to associate themselves so
specifically with something like
innovation it's almost always at the
expense of imitation because imitation
gets a bad rap
but these computers and all the
specialties that you're talking about
that's all based on henry ford's vision
with art too if you can if you can
repeat yourself if you're a master of
repetition you can be a master artist
because you just keep doing it and then
it's going to come around when that
thing is is when it's needed and you got
it
well now you're innovating that's the
scarcity model right if you're if you're
if you're making art for the masses or
technology for the masses then you
better have
the duplication gene down
but if you're looking for what nfts if
you're looking for
uh originals you know there's only
there's only one
whistler's mother there's only one mona
lisa but you could you could say that uh
an original is a bunch of replications
mixed pushed together into one new
uber rep replication that people
consider original like when i write
music i take notes from songs that i
heard in the past and create a new song
for sure we're all standing on the
shoulders of giants sure there's a
there's a great anime it's called dr
stone have you ever you ever hear of it
no i can't imagine you would have but uh
i've actually not watched a whole lot of
it but it's uh the premise is i'm gonna
get this wrong for fans of dr stone to
get mad at me uh this genius kid and his
friend i guess everybody turns to stone
in the world for some reason
and then thousands of years later for
some reason this ultra genius and his
you know friend or whatever or he he he
d stones them or whatever basically the
premise is he's this really smart kid in
a prehistoric time or an underdeveloped
time and he's developing technology so
i've only seen a couple episodes but
he's like i'm gonna make a cell phone
and the episode is actually him
directing people to find the medals and
explaining how vacuum tubes work and i'm
like it's like magic school bus but for
anime fans yeah i thought it was
actually really fascinating to to have
this um
action-oriented show for kids
explain how a vacuum tube works and he
as he's putting it together and making
the glass so it's fascinating he's like
okay to make the tube we need to make
glass here's what we need to find to
make the glass here's what we need to
make to blow the glass here's the metal
we need and then he tries to find the
proper filaments but he can't find the
right the you know that can withstand
the right temperatures i think it was
brilliant because when you when watching
that i think it would give a lot of
people especially millennials you know
i shouldn't pick on millennials
everybody needs to understand this that
when it goes into the the basics of
what's in your tv you have no idea the
precision
and the and the hard work and the trial
and error that went into inventing all
of these things and how we're very lucky
that we've written things down and
passed them on right you made my own
point better than i did that's what i
was trying to say when you're when
you're sitting there in the dark and you
can't get your own power back on you
realize just how decoupled you've come
from the chain of knowledge that allows
you to be your own solution right i
remember
if you ever watched star trek
absolutely
don't get me started on star trek what's
the what's the prime directive the prime
directive and star trek well you can't
interfere with another culture unless
they've reached what capabilities
correct all right good for you and
that's only and it's only because once
they reach warp they're inevitably going
to encounter other civilizations they
have to right um
so i'm hiking through um
peru
15 20 years ago
cusco to machu picchu i'm with some
buddies and we hired some sherpas to
help us because we had a lot of gear and
you know we didn't want to carry it all
and uh these guys were unbelievable
their giant lungs giant heart they would
start walking around 11 in the afternoon
we'd start walking around sorry 11 in
the morning we'd start walking around
six they'd pass us by four running in
bare feet right con per miso compare
miso anyway the i love these guys and i
had a uh i had a walkman i had a sony
walkman at the time and i was listening
to
soundgarden super unknown had just come
out
and i am just walking through the clouds
listening to this and it's so great and
on the last day i thought you know what
these guys were so awesome i i put the
headphones on one of the guys who had
never been below 12 000 feet in his
whole life by the way never heard an
electric guitar
and i put on spoon man
okay
so
watching his face
listening to chris cornell
sing and through those headphones it was
just like i knew in a second this was
this was my gift you violated the front
door
and i and i've been tortured ever since
because hey like somewhere in in the
andes is probably a
a stone built
thing that looks like a walkman
but but but then like what happened when
the batteries
went out and now the the magic sounds
are gone forever what
what's that gonna do
there's this fascinating quote i heard
that you could give christopher columbus
unlimited resources
and he would never build you a nuclear
submarine
because the the the the understanding of
of nuclear energy just it's beyond
anything they could put together it's
like a kid it's like adults aren't
capable of doing the thought processes
then that's part of why we have young
minds to do that and why are they still
in office politically there's something
that i always that that i um perhaps
mistakenly believe is fascinating
probably a lot of people just think i'm
an idiot but i i love asking people fine
line man
fine line between fascination and idiocy
so i i but but i've realized something
when i would ask people this question
how do coal power plants work how do
they create electricity or do you know
i'd imagine right
uh so uh what what do they do how does
how do we turn coal into electricity
well you got a turbine primarily and uh
i mean first you got to go into the
earth you got to get it out we live not
far we're sitting not far from where
that happens and then
you got bituminous and you got
anthracite and the approaches are
slightly different but in the end the
coal's got to wind up inside a turbine
you're getting way more specific than i
normally get
well i
go ahead with your explanation because i
have a slightly different well we just
boil water
oh okay right great yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're right you're like here's the
chemical breakdown uh we we burn stuff
we boil water yeah steam pressure spins
a turbine that's it rotating uh rotating
magnets generates electrical current and
vice versa uh how do we how does nuclear
energy how do we take nuclear or
radioactive uranium and turn into
electricity
um we we boil it even hotter we boil
water yeah
steam pressure spends a turbine and then
there's the uh the solar fields
the how do we you know
a lot of people think it's all
photovoltaic but actually many of them
just direct uh uh uh someone cracked me
someone did correct me on this once we
direct all these mirrors towards a vat
of salt water i believe it's saltwater
molten salt molten salt it's even more
because it holds the heat for longer and
then creates steam pressure spins a
turbine boiling water yeah boiling water
so you're talking about uh what do you
do when your power is out and you can't
you know get that going well the problem
is getting a turbine yeah there's your
problem so it's like even even
understanding something as basic as
steam pressure can spin something you
know it's not particularly complicated
how do you build a turbine you need some
copper you have to get a lot of copper
and coil it do it properly it's it's
crazy i just finished a show called uh
six degrees which sounds a little bit
like dr stone it's kind of a magic
school bus sort of thing that surprising
connections that take you down this
serendipitous line of
of uh
of invention but um part of the thing
that i really wanted to do with that
show was ex like
there were a few things that really just
chat my ass and and one is electric cars
and just the idea that we're so in love
with them because electricity is so much
better than
fossil fuels
and
you know if you
if you just follow the electricity back
from the plug yeah you know you're gonna
get to a spinning turbine and the odds
are
very very very high that turbine is
being powered by gas
or oil
and you just can't
you you you can't separate the two uh
for all the virtue in the world you just
can't do it we got storage issues with
power if we want to use wind what
happens when you know wind is low solar
doesn't work at night
uh geothermal is fantastic but you got
to be in the right positioning you know
the right place for it and so for the
time being we are heavily dependent on
fossil fuels which means burning them
and creating a lot of carbon lightning
is going to change when we can start
harnessing lightning
we're going to boil a lot of water nail
a battery and you know why we can't
though
we can't pronounce everything we can
well it's just we can't predict voltage
amperage the bolts are seemingly random
to us yeah you have to stick something
way up in the sky like a tether maybe
the space elevator to use as like a
lightning rod and then the elevator
itself the tether could be the super
conductor the issue is we can't we can't
properly measure the output
so while it seems to a lot of people
like oh you should be able to no we
can't because when all of our electro
systems have to be they're specific can
can the the the can we handle the load
typically you're right the load is way
beyond anything we normally deal with
but we also just don't know what it is
yeah it's lightning man it's like
yeah well i think the big point is the
fundamentals boiling water is
fundamental building a turbine is more
sophisticated the jobs that are going
wanting right now are fundamental
they're fundamental jobs and
the fact that most of us have become
disconnected from those jobs and the
people who do them
that
that's how we land the plane on the
skills gap it's not just a skill gap
it's a will gap you know it's a lack of
will on the part of many many many
millions of people who rely on the
people with the skill we're just not
properly gobs i'm actually a little
personal story here my sink just broke a
couple days ago and now it's been
leaking underneath i was like well gotta
gotta hire a guy to fix it i think i
want to fix it dude everybody's got that
story i want to get down there and fix
it i'll tell you this man when when it
hits the fan
very few people are going to be crying
for uh academics or buzzfeed reporters
but they're going to be begging for a
plumber yep they're going to say please
make my poop go away what do i do with
it that's that's my whole life now that
i i ask that question every day how long
do you want to wait
for the re refrigerator repairman for
the plumber and speaking of you said you
were in the sewer what was life like in
the sewers i've never been in one before
it's pretty great man tell me more i've
been i've been in one before
well i mean if you want to get back to
the fundamentals i mean that's how dirty
jobs started with the sewer inspector in
san francisco in 2002
and um
it's another it's
it's another world it's it's the classic
out of sight out of mind
thing
but you know this is a 120 year old
system
millions of bricks down there many many
many millions of roaches the size of
your thumb countless rats you're
knee-deep truly in a river of crap
and it's
good how much did they get paid
oh that sewer inspector did about well
it was a city job so he said i think it
was
five oh
wow you know private we should we gotta
i i i i volunteer to pay more taxes to
make sure those people get more money
man look he loved his job i mean eighty
two thousand dollars a year
he says how many years ago was this
this was close to 20. yeah this is that
that's a lot more compared to what it's
worth now so
like 120. so he's got like a chill chill
job down there he has no supervision
he has nobody monitoring him his job was
he he
he
hammered out the bricks that were
starting to rot and replace them so all
he did he'd go down there he'd mix his
mortar he'd hammer out the bricks that
had succumbed to the second law of
thermodynamics and he hammered in a new
one wearing like a full suit though
right no no no tyvek you know you know
like a rubber now he had a heavy duty
rubber suit but this that what people
don't understand about sewage is that
it's got chemicals and stuff it could be
it's corrosive right everything people
think their toilet is like different
from their sink like different drains go
to different pipes that go to no it all
goes to the same basic place so when it
rains
it being in a sewer during a rainstorm
is a whole different deal but also being
in a sewer
it's it's not just a river of urine and
crap coming at you it's all the stuff
that goes down the toilet it's like a
medicine cabinet it's it's it's it's uh
it's q-tips it's kotex is it just black
though
no it's it's it's more brown really some
of it is it's not as thick as you think
some of it sometimes it gets pretty
thick it depends how the
fixed film reactors and the lift pumps
or we should do a field trip yeah and uh
investigate further thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you